[Música]
en méjico ordenaron prisión preventiva
para jesús murillo karam el ex titular
de la procuraduría general de méxico
acusado en el caso de la desaparición de
los 43 estudiantes de ayotzinapa la
justicia considera que hay riesgo de que
huya del país
el papá francisco se pronunció luego de
haber sido criticado por su silencio
ante la persecución contra la iglesia
católica en nicaragua el sumo pontífice
dice que sigue de ser cada situación dos
días después de la detención del obispo
rolando álvarez
pero enciende las alertas por el
desgaste de machu picchu las autoridades
se han reunido con empresarios y
habitantes del sector para convenir una
manera de proteger el patrimonio
histórico luego de las protestas tras la
recomendación de la unesco de reducir
los visitantes viajes
bienvenidos a las noticias qué france24
dedica en este segmento al continente
americano mi nombre es marie claire a
calle prisión preventiva le dictaminaron
a jesús murillo karam el ex titular de
la extinta procuraduría general de
méxico que funcionaba como una fiscalía
a él lo acusan de tortura desaparición y
delitos contra la administración de
justicia por el caso de los 43
estudiantes de ayotzinapa el miércoles
24 agosto habrá una nueva audiencia en
la que murillo podrá presentar pruebas a
su favor
manuel acá no nos explica por qué la
justicia lo pone tras las rejas por el
momento
prisión preventiva para jesús murillo
karam un juez de ciudad de mexico ordenó
que el ex procurador general permanezca
preso hasta el miércoles por presunta
obstrucción a la justicia desaparición
forzada y tortura en el caso ayotzinapa
el sábado la fiscalía había ordenado la
detención de quien había ejercido el
cargo de procurador durante el gobierno
del ex presidente enrique peña nieto-
se trata de un hito en el caso
catalogado como crimen de estado por la
comisión de la verdad mexicana al ser el
primer arresto de alto nivel murillo fue
cuestionado por liderar la investigación
sobre la desaparición en 2014 de los 43
estudiantes de iguala en el oeste del
territorio mexicano se ha logrado la
pesquisa concluyó en 2015 que los
jóvenes habían sido secuestrados por
supuestos integrantes del cartel
guerreros unidos según la denominada
como verdad histórica el grupo los
habría asesinado y luego habrían sido
girados sus cuerpos una versión
desmentida por expertos independientes e
incluso rechazada por la onu y las 6h
que es un primer paso para que haya
justicia para que se castigue a quienes
cometieron ese crimen crimen de estado y
también para que se esclarezca lo que
sucedió esa terrible noche en 2015
murillo aseguró continuar con la
investigación hasta detener a los
culpables una promesa incumplida que
siete años después parece comenzar a
materializarse con las órdenes de
captura el exprocurador sino de al menos
80 militares y policías funcionarios
estatales y miembros del cartel
guerreros unidos todos involucrados en
el crimen una nueva ola de apagones en
cuba incremento del malestar social las
interrupciones del servicio eléctrico
pueden durar hasta siete horas diarias
en algunas ciudades las autoridades
cubanas afirman que los problemas se
deben a las obsoletas centrales
termoeléctricas ya sea por falta de
mantenimiento o por falta de dinero para
reponer algunas piezas claves jorge
hurtado nos explica
[Música]
'cuba lleva meses bajo constantes
apagones que dificultan el diario vivir
y generan pérdidas económicas para los
negocios privados la unión eléctrica de
cuba informa regularmente de esos cortes
con anticipación pero admite su falta de
capacidad para satisfacer la demanda
en el día de ayer se afectó el servicio
por déficit de capacidad durante las 24
horas del día la máxima afectación en el
horario pico fue mil 11 megavatios a las
20 40 horas el servicio se mantuvo
afectado durante toda la madrugada de
hoy
la crisis eléctrica es tal que de los 31
días de julio en 29 se registraron
apagones en lo que va de agosto el
comportamiento es similar según datos
oficiales esas interrupciones han
provocado varias protestas en distintas
localidades según medios independientes
el gobierno de cuba respondió a una
segunda noche de manifestaciones en
nuevitas deteniendo y agrediendo a
manifestantes pacíficos esta represión
no detendrá sus legítimas protestas
contra la represión y los continuos
apagones
el gobierno cubano dice que la crisis
eléctrica se debe a las obsoletas
centrales termoeléctricas y la falta de
fondos para mantenimientos una situación
agravada por las sanciones externas y el
incendio industrial ocurrido en matanzas
a principios de agosto la isla no tiene
dinero para comprar crudo en el exterior
y su principal proveedor venezuela está
suministrando le menos cantidad los
apagones reviven el fantasma de lo
vivido durante el periodo especial de
principios de los años 90 tras el
derrumbe del bloque soviético
otra de las noticias en cuba' es que el
país caribeño confirmó su primer caso de
viruela del mono el ministerio de salud
pública afirmó en un comunicado que
detectaron la enfermedad viral en un
turista que había llegado de italia esta
semana la persona se quedó en una casa
de alquiler y viajó a varios destinos en
las provincias occidentales lo buscó
atención médica el jueves y ahora
permanece en estado crítico en todo el
mundo se han confirmado cerca de 40.000
casos de viruela del mono según la o ms
el papá francisco finalmente se
pronunció sobre la situación de los
representantes de la iglesia católica en
nicaragua donde durante los últimos
meses se han avivado las detenciones a
sacerdotes y obispos las declaraciones
llegaron precisamente después de que el
obispo de matagalpa rolando álvarez
fuera arrestado el viernes el reporte es
de manuela caro
el vaticano rompe el silencio
dos días después de que rolando álvarez
el obispo de matagalpa un municipio en
el centro de nicaragua y crítico del
presidente nicaragüense daniel ortega
fuera detenido el papá francisco
finalmente se pronunció se guarda vicino
con preocupaciones y dolores sigo de
cerca con preocupación y dolor la
situación que tiene lugar en nicaragua
que involucra a personas e instituciones
ahora ya es primera convención quiero
expresar mi convicción y mi deseo de que
a través de un diálogo abierto y sincero
se puedan encontrar las bases para una
convivencia respetuosa y pacífica
convivencia y respeto y pacífica la
declaración llega tras las críticas a
las máximas autoridades de la iglesia
católica de permanecer ajenas a la
situación en el país centroamericano en
donde la persecución a sus
representantes por parte del gobierno de
daniel ortega es recurrente álvarez fue
detenido por supuestas acciones
desestabilizadoras y provocadoras junto
a cinco sacerdotes una ola de arrestos
que encendió las alarmas a nivel
internacional la organización de estados
américanos el consejo episcopal de
américa latina y el caribe y la onu
condenaron los hechos
las voces de rechazo se escucharon desde
costa rica donde reside una amplia
comunidad de nicaragüenses en el exilio
iglesia católica por parte de la vida
ortega ha catalogado a los obispos de
terroristas por su mediación en un
diálogo nacional que pretendía buscar
una solución a la crisis que atraviesa
el país desde 2018 año en el que explotó
el descontento social en las calles el
mandatario asegura que se trató de un
complot entre la oposición en eeuu para
destituirlo bajo la complicidad de los
sacerdotes
machu picchu una de las siete maravillas
del mundo está en peligro de desgaste
según advirtió el ministerio de cultura
y no sólo por el tiempo sino también
porque muchos visitantes tocan o se
apoyan en los muros incas incluso la
unesco recomendó reducir la cantidad de
visitantes diarios una idea que ha
despertado las protestas de los locales
ariana villacorta con los detalles
una de las siete maravillas del mundo
está en alerta la ministra de cultura de
perú betsy chávez advirtió que el
desgaste de machu picchu debería
preocupar no solo a los peruanos sino a
toda la humanidad en efecto hizo un
llamado a la conciencia lo que queremos
pedirles más bien a toda la ciudadanía a
todos nuestros hermanos turistas
nacionales y extranjeros es que
protejamos el patrimonio cultural esta
semana se han producido protestas en
aguascalientes ciudad desde la cual se
accede a la ciudad de la inca así como
debates sobre el aforo del lugar puesto
que la unesco recomienda una cifra de
visitantes diarios que no es compartida
por trabajadores de la zona en la región
en la que se encuentra el complejo
arqueológico existe un aforo autorizado
de cuatro mil cuarenta y cuatro personas
sin embargo en julio pasado la unidad de
gestión aprobó el incremento de la
cabida en machu picchu en mil espacios
esto para permitir la reactivación de
sus actividades duramente golpeadas
desde el inicio de la pandemia de kobe
19 pero el aumento en la demanda amenaza
su preservación
y pone en evidencia la necesidad de un
turismo sostenible y tenemos que
trabajar el tema de manera transversal
por un lado la protección del patrimonio
porque sin patrimonio no hay turismo
pero es importante también inyectar
estas palabras de turismo responsable el
lunes 15 de agosto la ministra se reunió
con el gobernador regional de cusco el
alcalde de machu picchu y con
representantes de los gremios que se
encargan del sector turístico en esta
región para impulsar nuevos acuerdos en
pro de salvaguardar el patrimonio
peruano así llegamos al final de las
noticias sigan conectados con nosotros
[Música]